25 years later get into karma linda
matilda whatever
that is really cool to know that you
were part of something that is
generational
hi dad are you in this family
i feel like danny and i just kind of
understood each other i don't know what
it was but
i i immediately felt a connection with
him
i am not a good dancer i've never been a
very good dancer and
it also wasn't too itty bitty pretty one
it was to harry belafonte's matilda
but they ended up changing the music the
apple never rocks far
from the trees being in the chokey was a
little scary too
and i'm going like this and it's because
it didn't smell good in there
it kind of smelled like rotten egg
[Music]
mara the inner child in me
is feeling so honored to sit down with
you and then i'm also wondering how many
people come up to you and say
i you were my whole childhood like how
often do you get that
probably at least once a week people
tell me how much they love matilda
it's so funny because i think when i was
a child i kind of couldn't conceive of
the magnitude of it all
i don't think i ever thought that you
know 25 years later i would still be
hearing from fans of it
25 years later yeah how old is matilda
four i'm six and a half mommy five then
it was six in august you're a liar was
there talk of this will be
a classic for kids because it was based
on a hugely popular book
do you think anybody knew i don't know
if we knew i think that we hoped that it
would be a hit
and i think that danny and and you know
everybody who wrote who wrote on it and
and worked on it
you know we really hoped that it would
do something and we knew that there
weren't a lot of movies like this
where you know intelligence is rewarded
and resourcefulness is rewarded there
also weren't that many many movies about
little girls and especially not little
girls you know who had
inner strength what also blew my mind in
my research was
according to the internet it was not a
box office success at the time
it was not a huge hit at the time it did
all right but it didn't do
very well but it it became a cult hit i
think probably the coolest thing is when
people tell me that they introduce their
children to it
so they'll say my daughter loves it my
son loves it i wash it with my kids and
that is really cool to know that you
were part of something that is
generational
it seems like you and danny did have
this special bond
you called him kind of your uncle on set
i feel like danny and i just kind of
understood each other
i don't know what it was but i i
immediately felt a connection with him
and i think that he was probably a lot
like a lot of the people in my family
just
full of good stories and a good sense of
humor and
very talkative and outgoing but also
very considerate and he thought a lot
about other people
and the same was true of ria she was
also the consummate performer but she
had a truly wonderful heart
funnily enough pam ferris your mommy
is a twit who played miss trunchbull she
was like that
embeth who played miss honey you know
she was like that too
i'm smart you're dumb i'm big you're
little i'm right you're wrong
and there's nothing you can do about it
i mean all those characters you just
mentioned danny and riaz and miss
trunchbull
danny's mean to you in the movies so
what was it like how did he balance out
i gotta go scream at you in this
scene we definitely laughed about it i
wanted to stay with miss honey oh miss
honey doesn't want you
why would she want some snotty
disobedient kid i think that sometimes
when children are acting
they can kind of get in and out of it
much easier because for children it's
kind of
more like pretending it's imagination
it's imagination and children
love imagination and they're all about
it and he taught me how to do really
cool things like
he taught me how to do pratfalls and he
taught me how to do
you know fake slaps and and stage combat
things and he would explain things to me
that was another great thing join the
ranks i think that uh probably the
funniest was
working with pam ferris because when pam
paris was not
in full tranchable gear she was just a
very nice woman
who you know never wore makeup but was
very beautiful and just wanted to talk
to you about her cats and her dogs and
her garden
she told us later that she felt like she
always tried to be really tough
and tried to like keep a distance from
the kid but then one of the kids came up
to her and grabbed her by the hand
and she knew that they knew that she was
really a sweetheart
i love that i actually want to show you
this clip because
of course ct was on set of matilda yes
25 years ago
and we did an interview with a little
mara
and here you are danny's really funny
and he's
really nice and um we tell jokes
and riddles he's a really funny guy and
when i come on to the set every day he
gives me a hug
that's true every day he would give me a
hug every day you know we would joke
with each other
and every day it really did feel like he
was kind of my favorite uncle
and also you'll probably notice that i
have my favorite teddy bear with me
[Laughter]
i think that was also important because
it meant that my mom and the people
around me
were happy with just letting me be a kid
too your family really
made sure you had a childhood it was
very important to my family that i
remained a child
so i shared a room with my sister until
we were i think i was 14 and we moved
house and
finally i got my own room and i went to
girl scouts and i went to a public
school
and also where i grew up in burbank
california it's
actually pretty common to be a child
actor watch this
do you have a favorite moment from
filming oh my gosh i have so many
favorite moments
doing the scene where we chase miss
french bowl out of the school was really
fun
and you can actually see me like hugging
jaclyn who plays amanda
and us just being so full of joy
[Music]
the scene where i'm under the table that
they had to fit me into a body cast for
and yeah that was a bit nerve-wracking
at first but it's it was
very very fun being put under the table
why did you have to be in a body cast
because they had to hook it up and they
had to take like this harness and
put like wires through it so i could
hold on to it like this
and i didn't need to let go and they got
my dress
and like two sizes bigger and uh so the
bodyguards would fit underneath it
it's a little claustrophobic it was a
little scary and you know
uh being in the choking was a little
scary too the apple never rocks
the worst part of the chokie was that it
smelled bad because they needed
something to put smoke in it
and the stuff they used to make smoke
did not smell so great
so that's actually why there's a scene
where miss honey removes me from the
choki
and i'm going like this and it's because
it didn't smell good in there
it kind of smelled like rotten eggs that
sulfur kind of smell it was kind of
gross
the montage scenes at the end with mbeth
as miss honey that felt good because
we actually got to have real
conversations and we actually had to got
to do really fun things like going
rollerblading and having a picnic
is it true that in the that famous
little bitty pretty one scene
yeah where she's really getting her
powers going yeah that danny had the
whole
cast and crew dancing with you he did i
am not a good dancer i've never been a
very good dancer so i think that i went
up to danny and i was like danny
i'm a little bit nervous and he said
okay well here's the rule
that day everybody has to dance so
everybody danced and my mom was dancing
and you know the camera operators were
dancing and the assistant directors were
dancing
and it also wasn't too itty bitty pretty
one it was to
harry belafonte's matilda
uh but they ended up changing the music
and i mean they're both great songs why
did they do that
i don't know maybe i don't know but but
i think that they're both wonderful
songs i just think it's so funny when
people say
oh that song reminds me of you and i'll
think well that's so funny because
that's not the song i associate with the
scene that's not your memory
yeah by the way you were already having
a hard time dancing and then they
changed what
you were even going to so well now i
have possible deniability if people
think that i'm not a good dancer i can
say well i was actually dancing to a
different song
i i don't know if there's a basic
explanation but you know as a child i
remember the magic and the wonder of all
the stuff's flying around
how did they do some of that some of it
was computer like the chips flying
around
that was that was computer but a lot of
things were on poles or they had people
moving it
in fact the doll i remember there was
somebody making her dance they
they put i think like holes in the couch
and they had wires there and they made
her
dance just like that and it was so fun
do you still have the doll
i think i still have the doll somewhere
i wish i did but for a long time
she was up on the mantelpiece in my
house she had kind of a place of honor
there
we named her wanda any other keepsakes
anything you or your family took from
set
yeah i still have a hat that says
matilda and i had a matilda jacket
and i remember really liking the dress
that i wore at the end
uh where miss honey and i are having a
tea party so i got to keep that dress
and i was very excited about that i
still have pictures of us at the
playground and just having fun
and it's still you know it's still just
a big part of my life
yeah i mean this is a sensitive question
to ask you and i was thinking what a
time that must have been for you to be
on this incredible movie set and but you
also have to go through your mom having
cancer yeah
so what was the balance of that like for
you and how does it make you remember
that time i think that it was probably
the best thing that could have happened
to me at that time because
it kept me away from worrying and it
made me not focus on it and in fact i i
realized later on
that they would be planning these fun
weekends and things for me to do and you
know danny and ria would
take me to the theater to see a play or
to the movies
or to just hang out at their house
things like that
and that was all usually done when my
mother was in the hospital
so it really did keep me distracted and
it really did keep me happy and i had a
lot of people on set who really loved me
and
really took care of me they dedicated
the movie to my mother and i'm so glad
that they did that because my mother
worked so hard and she loved that movie
so much
and she loved matilda so much so i
really loved that they did that
i i felt so glad when i saw that in the
credits and i still feel happy when i
see that now
my mother loved the book of matilda so
much she actually used to read it out
loud to my brother's classrooms one of
my earliest memories
is her bringing me along i think i maybe
had a cold or an ear infection or
something as a very small child
and i just curled up in the back of the
room while she read it to them and
i just remember just being entranced and
loving this story so much
and then now we're sitting here 25 years
later and it's still this incredible
experience and moment in your life
yeah it's it is remarkable to me i think
that there was a time in my life where i
felt very frustrated because i felt
almost like
you know people knew me for matilda but
not for myself and so it was strange it
felt like i was sort of being
overshadowed
and i think that i really struggled with
that for a while but
now i think i'm at a place in my life
where i i just feel
really grateful and really happy that i
ever had that chance
will we ever see you in a matilda sequel
because danny devito said
he said he could see that one day maybe
matilda has a daughter
did he see that did he say that for a
long time i was very resistant to the
idea of a matilda sequel because i was
like well the story wraps up so nicely
you know maybe there shouldn't be a
sequel but i love working with danny
and the thing is i i don't act that much
anymore but when i do it's usually with
people i love
so i i mean i i would not turn down the
chance to work with him again
i don't think okay so it's a maybe
for a long time i probably would have
told you no but you know i
i think especially like in the past few
months like since i've been doing cameo
on instagram
just all the messages that i get from
people who love it it it really does
mean a lot
it it sounds like that that fills you up
that gives you warmth it does
for a long time i think i couldn't
connect with it i i just kind of didn't
understand it i i had imposter syndrome
but lately i'm just like oh wow people
are
showing this to their kids people people
have named their children
after characters from matilda and also
people who had rough childhoods
reach out to me all the time to say
thank you so much matilda got me through
this because i knew
that it wasn't always going to be like
that and that just i mean i'm getting
goosebumps just thinking about that
just thinking about how giving people
hope is such an amazing thing
so i love that i was able to do that